retour aux sources
walt hérauville elle est chouette ma
caméra ouais en fait un reportage à la
ferme de bel air tout le monde est
gentil mais ils sont réservées ce sur
quoi votre reportage sur les amish mais
c'est pas des amis chez un légal et bel
air bien sûr que si
la maman a vécu ici il ya très longtemps
elle est toujours ici
elles tiennent pas beaucoup quand on
cherche ses racines donc elles étaient
ensemble dans l'étranger c'est ça excuse
moi on peut finir six pieds sous terre
s'en rendent au stade nuit tu filmes
tout un tas de choses qui sont pas tes
affaires
j'essaie de télé le fait pas regretter
il avait une bonne raison nous fait
revenir ici l'ultime réponse de la saga
n'a pas de voiture pas de téléphone
il ya personne à moins de vingt bornes
paranormal activity in et off line dès
le 3 février inédit sur choc